- Hey, everybody!
Welcome back to Kevin's Korner!
I'm Kevin.
Today we're gonna be wrapping presents.
It's the holiday season,
and what do all of the
holidays have in common?
Presents!
Christmas
presents!
Hanukkah
Kwanzaa
presents!
So now I'm gonna show you
how to wrap the best present ever.
Presents!
You need four items:
wrapping paper, tape,
scissors and a present.
Of course, you dummy!
Today, I'm gonna be wrapping this football
that I got for my little brother Kyler.
We don't have the best relationship,
but hopefully, this takes
it to the right start.
Hot, hot, hike!
So, first, you get yout paper out,
put it like so.
You take your item -
footballs are kinda hard to wrap.
Make sure you measure the
right amount of paper.
You don't wanna just waste it.
What are you - a tree killer?
So after I've measured the paper,
I'm gonna cut it.
Gah!
(beep)
Just be careful,
some of this paper can
really cut your finger.
Just go with the flow, just go.
Now we have the perfect amount of paper.
So what we're gonna do
is start to fold it.
And then now you wanna get the tape.
Um, tape, tape, tape, tape, tape, tape,
tape.
You can't really fold
anything without tape.
Tiffany, hey, it's Kevin!
I must have misplaced the
tape that you lend me.
Is it okay if I come over
you to get some more?
I didn't, I didn't lose, I didn't.
Oh, we're gonna bring that up right now.
Do you not wanna be an adult?
Christmas is ruined, Tiffany!
(sad music)
(thuds against floor)
So sometimes when you can't find the tape
you have to improvize.
So I use some tape off an old present
and I'm gonna it use on this new one
for my little brother Kyler.
Put your tape like so -
and I didn't measure this right, I didn't.
Why is this so hard?
You just gotta get creative with it.
It's easy to wrap presents without tape.
That's it.
Also I just wanna say something.
You know, there're sometimes people,
your ex-girlfriend who live next door,
and they just don't want to help you out
because they already lent you tape.
You are not responsible, Kevin.
Roger doesn't lose tape.
Roger has a job.
Well, guess what, Tiffany,
Roger sucks.
Who am I kidding, Roger is a great guy.
I couldn't find the tape.
That doesn't mean I
don't love you anymore.
You know, fine, fine,
fine, fine, fine, I don't,
I don't need your tape.
(sad music)
So, the whole point of the
holidays are not presents.
It's the spent time with your loved ones.
So grab someone tight
and let them know that you're there,
you're there forever.
(sad music)
(loud thuds)
Where's that tape?